to present the Award for Best Picture an
actor who made oscar history in 1963 by
becoming the first black man to win the
best actor award something that has yet
to be repeated he made a lot of other
actors possible including myself
ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner Sidney Poitier
through pathways in the heart and across
rivers of the mind instinct guide us to
a place somewhere in human consciousness
that has no known address there we look
inside ourselves confront our demons and
do battle with a mystery call the
creative process sometimes we win
sometimes not such battles such journeys
are the stuff of which movies are made
and dreams are spun among some of you
here who have been there sit those of
you who have brought us to this next
moment to all of you the academies
appreciation the nominees for Best
Picture of the year are
Apollo 13 Brian Grazer producer
babe George Miller Doug Mitchell
Bill Miller producing
Braveheart Mel Gibson Alan Ladd jr.
Bruce baby produces
the postman mario vittorio check egoriy
Gaetano Daniele producers Sense and
Sensibility
Lindsay Duran producer
and the Oscar for Best Picture is
presented to Braveheart
we've only got 45 seconds and I don't
want to hog the limelight from these two
gentlemen who really deserve the statue
thank you again all those people I think
before and I owe a special debt of
gratitude to Bruce here in an Alan take
it away fellas - I'd like to endorse all
those racks and that and people that Mel
thanked and I'd also like to thank and
to those that was inspired and supported
me along the way and I truly Adam did it
in particular - Nigel Sinclair - Steve
mcavee d ed LaMotta and Geoff Berg and
to you Mel I thank you for the
opportunities that you've given me for
your encouragement loyalty and
friendship and to Joe Stewart and Jane
thanks for your torrents and patience
and luck thank you I can say thank you
very much to my family thank you very
much
you